bonjour à tous je voudrais dire le
plaisir de vous retrouver pour ce point
presse avec annie genevard d'abord
quelques mots de l'actualité politique
de notre mouvement et de l'agenda
l'agenda de cette semaine nous verra
demain par le plus exactement oui c'est
ça demain réunion publique d'eric woerth
à 19h notre secrétaire général se rendra
au palais des sports de puteaux dimanche
d'autres réunions de notre mouvement
avec la fête départementale du rhône en
présence de laurent wauquiez président
des républicains à 11 heures puis à midi
la fête départementale d'indre et loire
en présence d'eric woerth secrétaire
général de notre mouvement et cela aura
lieu à saint cyr sur loire à l'ordre du
jour de notre point presse les migrants
est également le point sur la politique
menée à l'heure actuelle par le
gouvernement en direction des autoroutes
si je puis dire mais peut-être s'arrêter
déjà pour rappeler que les républicains
ne pourront se contenter de ce qu'a
décidé
monsieur 15 9 concernant la le
démantèlement de calais vous le savez
nous sommes montés au créneau le
mouvement des républicains d'ailleurs à
travers une pétition que nous relayons
d'ailleurs par un tract une pétition qui
dit non au plan cazeneuve qui dit non à
cette répartition de dix mille migrants
sur le territoire français dix mille
migrants qui auront était imposé par un
plan de monsieur cazeneuve sans aucune
concertation avec les élus locaux
vous le savez cette répartition s'est
fait dans plusieurs régions de france
sans que les présidents de régions de
soins informer les associations de
maires ne sont informés les départements
de soins formé au point même que
monsieur 15,9 dans sa directive avait
même précisé que cela devait se faire
sans concertation avec les élus locaux
nous condamnons de manière très forte
cette absence de respect des élus car
c'est évidemment un comportement qui est
tout sauf républicain
cette méthode inadmissible conduit
d'ailleurs un discrédit de ce qui a été
décidé car là où il y aurait pu y avoir
intelligence et pragmatisme en
conservant les élus puisque des élèves
soit parce qu'ils sont équipés dans leur
propre commune pour accueillir des
migrants imposé à des collectivités qui
ne sont pas prêtes
sans que cela soit vu en amont nous
imaginons et on le sait pour ceux pour
qui cela s'est déjà passé il ya des
difficultés parfois d'intégration de
scolarité et que les équipements qui
pour certains ont été présentés ne sont
pas obligatoirement adapté à l'accueil
de ces migrants
donc premièrement nous condamnons cette
méthode qui est tout sauf républicaine
par ailleurs il ne faut pas perdre de
vue que les dix mille personnes qui sont
donc à l'heure actuelle à calais n'ont
pas demandé l'asile en france ces
personnes avait vocation elle souhaitait
quitter la france pour se rendre en
grande bretagne
donc nous sommes en train le
gouvernement est en train de fixer sur
le territoire national dix mille
personnes qui au départ souhaité quitter
la france pour se rendre au royaume uni
nous souhaitons donc que le gouvernement
s'inspire de la méthode de nicolas
sarkozy au moment de son get qui avait
été avec un accord avec tony blair pour
que lorsqu'il y avait eu afin de
sangatte c'était ces personnes qui
souhaitaient rejoindre le royaume uni
avait été accompagnée et avait donc
rejoint le royaume uni n'était pas
rester sur le territoire français nous
demandons donc au gouvernement de
s'inspirer de cette de cette expérience
et nous pointons du doigt
donc cette responsabilité qui est la
sienne dans la situation que nous
connaissons à l'heure actuelle qui plus
est nous le savons tous dix mille
migrants ça n'est pas le chiffre
définitif
nous ne sommes loin d'avoir bloqué les
flux migratoires et pour cela vous le
savez les républicains proposent
plusieurs proposent en effet des
solutions sur lesquelles annie genevard
va revenir et je voudrais quand même
aussi vous rappeler que depuis six mois
c'est moins de 20% de reconduite à la
frontière et que seulement 4% sont
déboutés du droit d'asile
donc à ce jour évidemment c'est toute
une politique migratoire qui est à
revoir et c'est sur ces propositions que
j'ai passé la parole annie merci alors
restons sur la question des migrants et
sur calais je voudrais d'emblée dissiper
ce qui pourrait être une incertitude
nous voulons le démantèlement de kehl et
nous considérons que les calaisiens que
le maire de calais que les élus de ce
territoire vivent quelque chose
d'extrêmement difficile et que la
communauté nationale ne peut pas y être
indifférente
la question qui se pose est de savoir si
la méthode préconisée par le ministre de
l'intérieur est la bonne méthode
hélas comme cela a été dit nous avons
les plus grands doutes
quelques chiffres du passé qui nous
invite à boire beaucoup de
circonspection
il y avait à calais en 2012
900 personnes il y en a aujourd'hui près
dix mille donc un phénomène qui n'est
pas maîtrisée est évidemment beaucoup
plus difficile à contenir et à résoudre
qui nous dit que demain dans la
dissémination sur le territoire national
des migrants de calais nous
n'assisterons pas exactement à la même
inflation de personnes ce qui nous
mettrait face à une situation
extrêmement difficile
deuxième point qui nous invite à ne pas
faire confiance au ministre de
l'intérieur
c'est effectivement l'éviction des élus
locaux
ça c'est quelque chose c'est une faute
majeure que le ministre a commise et qui
ne peut pas appeler de notre point de
vue autre chose que de la défiance
nous n'avons plus confiance en monsieur
15 9 après les déclarations qu'il a
faites
alors il faut effectivement s'inspirer
de l'exemple de sangatte il faut
impliquer
naturellement les anglais puisque
ces personnes qui sont à calais veulent
aller en angleterre elles ne veulent pas
rester sur le territoire ça a été
parfaitement dit et il faut que nous
mettions sur la table les solutions que
nous les républicains nous envisageons
alors point sur lequel nous sommes tous
d'accord parce qu'il est de bon ton de
mettre l'accent sur nos différences mais
aussi pas mal de points sur lesquels
nous sommes d'accord nous sommes
d'accord sur le démantèlement de calais
il faut démanteler calais c'est la
priorité
tout simplement parce qu'il ya une
situation humaine sanitaires sociales
politiques territoriales qui deviendra
dans très peu de temps absolument
intenable
c'est aujourd'hui le plus grand
bidonville d'europe et le gouvernement à
sa part sa part de responsabilité en
laissant développer le grossissement de
calais ils se il rend plus difficile
chaque jour la sortie
la sortie de crise et les solutions
alors nos solutions et bien c'est de
démanteler en modélisant sangatte
c'est de revoir schengen il faut
absolument qu'on défende mieux nos
frontières lorsque l'europe a été
construite
lorsque schengen a été imaginée nous
n'étions pas du tout dans les mêmes
dispositions
et face aux phénomènes migratoires que
nous connaissons aujourd'hui
il faut donc adapter schengen la réalité
du moment
il faut que la france garde sa
souveraineté garder sa souveraineté
c'est défendre ses frontières on l'a dit
mais c'est aussi déterminé qui nous
voulons sur notre territoire
ça fait partie des prérogatives de
toutes les nations enfin il faut
reconduire plus efficacement il faut
accueillir à la fois les réfugiés de
guerre mais pour accueillir les réfugiés
de guerre qui est une tradition
humaniste des grands pays
démocratique il faut pouvoir contenir et
raccompagnés dans leurs pays ce qui ne
sont pas là parce que ils sont poussés
par la guerre qui sévit dans leur pays
autrement dit il faut raccompagné plus
efficacement qu'on ne le fait
aujourd'hui cela a été 10 - 20 % de
reconduite à la frontière aujourd'hui
comment voulez vous qu entre les
demandeurs d'asile les migrants
économiques
le regroupement familial l'accueil des
étrangers les irréguliers
comment voulez vous que ça ne
grossissent pas un flux qu'on est de
plus en plus en difficulté de contrôler
et qui suscite de fait dans la
population française
beaucoup d'inquiétude alors que nous
voulons au contraire faire en sorte que
les choses se passent bien voilà je
terminerai par le propos une madame le
maire de calais elle a dit quelque chose
qui est terrible et dieu sait pourtant
qu'elle travaille que les services de
l'état
quel travail pour sa ville est beaucoup
de courage madame bouchard a dit ce plan
arrive trop tard ce plan arrive trop
tard car le gouvernement ne maîtrise pas
le phénomène au fond et c'est là dessus
que je terminerai pas de confiance dans
le gouvernement pour traiter ces
questions et pas de maîtrise du
phénomène et ça c'est tout à fait
préoccupant et c'est la raison pour
laquelle aux républicains nous sommes
résolus à ne pas laisser le gouvernement
faire ce qu'il entend par ce que nous
pensons que c'est une mauvaise chose à
la fois pour ces migrants mais aussi
pour notre pays
sur les autoroutes
alors un petit mot sur les autoroutes
qui sera sans doute moins long même si
il ne manque pas de saveur
vous allez voir puisque nous avons une
annonce il y a peu de l'augmentation des
tarifs de péage
donc on voit que les socialistes après
avoir annoncé la baisse des impôts n'ont
pas tenu une semaine avant de trouver
quelques augmentations à nous infliger
donc là il s'agit des tarifs de péage 1
milliard d'euros qui seront destinés à
améliorer le réseau autoroutier
donc cette amélioration à hauteur d'un
milliard d'euros ça n'est pas rien sera
destinée à financer les des opérations à
peu près 30 opérations des échos
aménagements on devrait nous dit le
gouvernement créer 5000 emplois
donc tout ça reste malgré tout à étudier
précisément et à chiffrer précisément on
sait que la hausse sera de 0 3 0 4% par
an mais que cette hausse s'ajoute à une
autre couche plus importante qui est je
crois de 0 8% alors pour certains c'est
un scandale parce que eh bien les
entreprises privées perçoivent des
bénéfices substantiels dans
l'administration qu'elles font du réseau
autoroutier le bénéfice est à deux
chiffres entre 20 et 24 %
donc la question qu'on peut se poser est
de savoir s'il fallait que ce soit le
contribuable qui une fois de plus soit
sollicité alors qu'il a été tant de fois
sous ce quinquennat
près de 40 milliards d'impôts
supplémentaire sur les ménages lesquels
ménages ont échappé de peu à la taxe
régionale qui finalement a été abandonné
et c'est là on voit que l'on voit une
certaine forme d'amateurisme du
gouvernement moi qui suivit la loi notre
de bout en bout
on avait posé un certain nombre de
questions le basculement des compétences
de la compétence économique en totalité
sur les régions fait état d'un manque à
gagner de plusieurs centaines de
millions d'euros qui manquent aux
régions aujourd'hui pour conduire le
l'action économique
donc il aurait peut-être fallu se poser
la question
un petit peu avant en tout état de cause
cette taxe régionale ne verra pas le
jour parce que les présidents
ils sont majoritairement hostiles oui
les prisons c'était peut-être pour
rappeler aujourd'hui apparemment une
communication et un focus de la part du
gouvernement sur le nombre de places de
prison
quelque chose là encore d'assez
incompréhensible en fin de quinquennat
de prendre conscience de la situation
absolument dramatique des prisons
françaises
je dois quand même vous vous rappelez
quand 2011 nicolas sarkozy avait fait
voter un plan qui prévoyait la
construction de 24 mille places de
prison l'objectif était donc de porter à
80 mille places le parc carcéral
français pour faire face à la
surpopulation carcérale
mais au 1er mai 2012 le parc carcéral
français n'était doté que de 57 milles
places alors que la france comptait plus
de soixante sept mille personnes
incarcérées et là à l'heure actuelle
aujourd'hui en 2016 le parc carcéral a
carrément inchangé 58 1507 place avec un
nombre évidemment de personnes écrouées
qui a augmenté à pratiquement 69 mille
personnes quand parallèlement le royaume
uni lui pour la même population que la
france est à 96 mille places de prison
supplémentaires
donc nous voulons aujourd'hui dénoncé
cette irresponsabilité gouvernementale
peut nous voyons à nouveau sur ce sujet
comme sur un autre de mesures qui
avaient été prises précédemment qui
n'ont pas été suivies et qui à quelques
mois d'une élection présidentielle
ici comme ailleurs ne dupe personne
peut-être aussi un petit mot sur une
situation qui pour certains d'entre nous
a paru un peu ubuesque et je ne peux pas
m'empêcher de dire quelques mots sur
notre président hollande président
hollande qui je dois dire au delà de sa
politique menée nous a aujourd'hui
peut-être interpeller en tout cas
surpris à deux reprises je dois vous
dire que lorsqu'on parle du statut
d'homme d'état et tout le monde en ce
moment est en train de faire référence à
d'autres personnalités qui ont été
président de la république et peut-être
aussi avec annie et l'ensemble des
républicains aujourd'hui avoir une
pensée affectueuse pour jacques chirac
en lui souhaitant un prompt
rétablissement
où je vois que les uns les autres
essayent de s'arracher des héritages de
manière absolument indécente
françois hollande lors des journées du
patrimoine aura carrément trouvé normal
de se mettre en position de se faire
prendre en photo derrière un des
barrières depuis son bureau de l'elysée
je ne sais pas si les uns les autres
vous avez vu cette image
c'était françois hollande muséifier
avant l'heure c'est à dire il se prêtait
au jeu des photos derrière son bureau le
au moment des journées du patrimoine
c'est quelque chose qui a choqué plus
sûrs personne d'entre nous et je tenais
ici a souligné
l'anachronisme de cette personne de ce
président de la république qui parfois
discrédite la fonction présidentielle
mais par ailleurs il semblerait que à
quelques milliers de kilomètres d'ici
françois hollande soit reconnue
autrement avec un prix qui est donc lui
ai remis du meilleur chef d'état au
monde
en l'occurrence pour sa politique de
lutte contre le terrorisme
je dois ici souligné que nous voulons
que ce prix soit interprété surtout pour
un hommage à toutes les forces de
l'ordre à tous ceux qui au jour chaque
jour travail j'allais dire dans
l'anonymat le plus total pour essayer de
déjouer des attentats
car ce que nous avons
onu en france depuis quelques mois avec
plus de 230 victimes fait que nous
devons ici rendre hommage à ce prix à
travers non pas la personnalité du
président de la république mais à
travers tous ceux qui ont contribué à
faire en sorte que des attentats soient
des jouets mais nous ne pouvons nous
satisfaire chez les républicains que ce
prix soit remis comme quelqu'un qui a
lutté contre le terrorisme car nous
persistons à penser qu'il y avait des
mesures à prendre supplémentaires toutes
celles que les parlementaires ont
proposé à chaque projet de loi de lutte
contre le terrorisme ou systématiquement
toute proposition émanant des
républicains a été rejeté
aujourd'hui il faut avoir cela en tête
ce sujet mérite en effet une unité
nationale mais elle mérite aussi le
respect de l'opposition nationale qui
n'a de cesse de faire des propositions
et qui n'est jamais entendue active la
rétention administrative d'un outil
majeur de même de lutte contre le virus
n'a été rétablie qu'après les attentats
les plus sanglants
alors que nous réclamions depuis des
mois c'est la preuve tout de même qu' il
y avait en la matière beaucoup de
légèreté et beaucoup de dogmatisme dès
lors que la proposition venait de
l'opposition elles n'étaient pas
audibles